all right
okay
you know what
let's
do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to another episode of your
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
anyways y'all welcome back to riffing
with griffin
it's been a week since the infamous slap
i want to see how we feeling today after
a week i'm going to talk about that give
you a little bit of my thoughts
[Applause]
my there buddy jerrod carmichael put out
a piece of art man just
just a work of art and i want to talk
about that give him his flowers
and i went and saw the movie morbius
this new marvel sony edition of the
movie and i'm gonna give you a piece of
that
and we'll see how i'm feeling about that
other than that
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back to riffing with
griffin
riffing with griffin we ain't spliffing
the riffing with griffin nation welcome
we are live we are live right now on
youtube so welcome to the rifle with
griffin show
but first before we even start that
let's uh pay some bills
um shout out right now to helix sleep
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life find your perfect mattress at
helixsleep.com
griffin
all right y'all welcome to the show
and
excuse me and you know make sure you
subscribe you know i really appreciate
that when you hit the subscribe button
subscribe share it you know do all the
things that people do
you know to help support a podcast
so do all that stuff man so i you know i
appreciate that and i never talk about
this enough but i also have the air
griffin store eric griffin store i got
like eric griffin gaming merch i got
like just funny merch that i have in
there if you want to support me get a
t-shirt a sweatshirt a mug i love the
mugs
so look out for that i got it pinned
right now so if you want to go to the
airgrid restore i got a link in the in
the thing so check that out
and also as always i'm on twitch daily
eric griffin gaming if you want to watch
me play
excuse me and this saturday actually
this saturday if you play warzone i'm
doing private
private matches with the fans and
friends so if you come to my
channel saturday morning you'll see me
signed in and then you'll see how you
could join the match and and i play you
know we want to try to get 100 people in
there so we could do like a big the main
warzone map so if you're into that and
you want to play with me come to the
channel and we'll do that all right
so anyways like i say i got the store
right there so check me out if you're
interested in
getting t-shirts and all that kind of
stuff
all right
but anyways welcome back to riffin with
griffin y'all i was just in texas i was
in san antonio texas shout out to lol
comedy club had some great shows they
really were i really felt like
i really felt like the people were there
for comedy and they felt good about
comedy and they wanted to be there and
they were ready to experience all the
things that comedy had to offer so shout
out to all the people that showed up and
uh you know so that was good
san antonio in san antonio was it was
hot one day cold or like like humid hot
it is what it is but you know we had um
[Music]
i had a great time uh shout out to my
opener leah lamar she came out there
with me and she she's funny check her
out and yes this is live chat so if
you're in the chat right now on youtube
we are live you know so if you have like
a decent question you want to ask you
can put it in there right now if you
have something to say i'm right there i
accept super chats and all that kind of
stuff so if you want to support the show
please support the show you know there's
links the on the youtube page to support
if you want to support with paypal
whatever you want to do it and also
don't forget about my patreon too i
forgot about that patreon i got some
some stuff coming out for that too man i
do have a patreon at eric griffin
eric griffin
uh you know patreon eric griffin patreon
at eric griffin so if you want to if you
want to be a part of that support just
supporting me there too you could do
that too man so i you know i appreciate
all the support i'm trying to do my
thing uh you know check me out on gender
gen is coming back probably in may so i
still got that podcast with my buddy
matthew espinoza he's 25. i'm 50 and we
just talk about the different
generations and as always you can catch
me on king and the sting i know there's
like everybody's like i don't know
what's going on we can't even stick
still on king of this thing recorded an
episode today i got the same shirt on so
it is what it is whenever that episode
comes out so i got let's like three
episodes that are two episodes we
already filmed with me that are coming
out so make sure you check me out on
that too so
you know
um anyways welcome back to uh roofing
with griffin so
this is what i want to talk about so i
was in uh um so it's been a week you
know it's been a week since the infamous
slap last week's episode i went in it
was a complete hour on the chris rock
tape i even put like uh some stand-up up
i had this two-minute clip i put up that
cause i just i was feeling i was in my
feelings about what happened and now
i've had like a week to sit around and
be like how do i feel now about
everything that happened what are the
implications of it how is it going to
affect our lives and uh
and
and all that and i and i really have
some some some thoughts about it man
i do have some thoughts about it so
here's what i'm thinking now
so it's been a week right
so you know everybody knows and people
are kind of sick of talking about it and
all that too i think i think it was one
of those things that was so like wow and
it was like everywhere and then people
kind of just that's how we are we like
to move on from [ __ ] quick you know and
i get that but i wanted to talk about
because
me being at this comedy club and how i
feel like it affected the shows because
here's something i was thinking the
silver lining of what happened right the
silver lining for say for comedy for
comics
so
let's say
will smith doesn't slap him
and he just has a look on his face
him and his wife are upset about this
nothing joke right let's say you know
what would have happened the next day i
think chris rock would have been dragged
through the mud and it would have been a
whole thing about pro whatever apple
apple whatever the disease whatever the
minor disease she has with when you lose
your hair right
um what minor whatever maybe you think
it's major i'm not gonna downplay it
whatever she has that she's bald and it
affects her life okay all right so let
me not downplay that
i think that it would have been bad for
comics and it would have been more
attacks on comics in terms of
this oversensitivity over correction
with comics this whole thing about like
you know what you can and cannot say
like how everybody nitpicks the things
that you say to the point where they
assume your intent
you know they assume your intent and
they think your intent is the worst
possible thing ever and they attack you
for that i think that if will smith had
not gotten up and made a fool of himself
that would have been the thing it would
have been bad for comics because it
would have been another thing where it's
like well i mean comedians are going too
far and it would have been like i think
that would have been he wins
him and his wife win
instead he did this thing where he
slapped him
i think that benefits comics and i'll
tell you why because i think that slap
woke everybody up
i think it woke everybody up i think
everybody looked at this and went oh man
i think we're overreacting it was just a
joke
why are we over
like i think people saw what will smith
did and went oh that's not a good look i
don't think it was that serious for just
a small simple joke and i think
everybody's been acting like you know
that's how they've been acting they've
been acting like in their minds they act
like oh comedy's going too far and like
and i think they just reminded us that
it's just a show that it's just a joke
it's just for fun and that the intention
is not so terrible as they think because
what actually happened the result
no one wants to do that
no one wants to be somebody who is
revered and looked at as someone who's a
good person and then see the worst of
them over a joke
and i think that everybody now is like
oh wow i think we we went too far
and i think people are starting to be
like oh i actually just want to go watch
comedy again and uh laugh at the world
laugh at things and i think that that's
a good thing i think the silver lining
in this is people are wanting to see
comedy again i think people have been
like oh man like like what makes people
feel so like
this range of emotions like comedy and i
think that now like chris rock's tour
sold out people want to go see what he
has to say and i think people that are
showing up to comedy clubs now for the
most part are like yeah
they're supportive they're like you know
what this is just jokes and funny and i
think that people that find like that
don't they can't take a joke stay home
comedy's not for you and it's okay just
like i don't like spoken word poetry i'm
not going to a spoken word poetry jam
and then complaining about spoken word
poetry so i think it's like if you don't
like comedy stay home i don't want to
see you at the comedy gig i think you
should just stay home but the people
that are into it go with an open heart
and open mind and realize you know we're
gonna talk about all kinds of different
things and it's all about intent and
perspective like just going back to the
incident
you have to ask yourself what is the
premise you're arguing from
there's two different premises first
premise that chris rock is a
mean-spirited person who is trying to
hurt their feelings and ruin their night
if that's the premise you're going with
when i'm speaking to you i need to know
that that's your premise that that's
what you believe that's what you believe
and so now i know when i'm talking to
you that's what you believe so i
understand what the venom is coming from
if my premise that i believe is
the guy was just poking fun and he made
a little innocuous dad joke at their
expense because that's what he does at
the oscars and that's why they had him
here because if i believed he was a
mean-spirited person do you think that's
the joke he would have done
so if chris rock is a terrible
mean-spirited person do you think
that's the joke he would have done
like that's
that's the premise
like of all the things he could talk
about
all of will smith and and their business
that's in the streets that's out in
public consumption
do you think if he was a mean-spirited
person that a g.i jane joke would be the
joke he would have went with
so i don't
believe that premise i believe it was
just what it was nothing okay so
so you have to acknowledge on the other
side that this is the possibility that
the possibility is that you're
overreacting
and i'll take into consideration okay i
see what you believe you believe that it
that this was the worst thing he could
have possibly done and he was a terrible
person mean-spirited and you know he was
trying to ruin everything okay i
understand you believe that i don't
believe that
okay so then now we know where we're at
we can agree to disagree and but
hopefully you can also see this side of
it too you know what i mean
all right before i continue let me shout
out thank you so much for the super
chats
omi queen thank you uh miss informed
okay i like that misinformed i don't
know if that's a girl but that's a great
name if that's a girl and raquel would
wow i feel like it's all ladies giving
giving me the support what's going on
fellas you know get get with it thank
you for the super chats i i appreciate
the support for the show it really it
really helps me and you know helps grow
the show and everybody hit the likes hit
the shares you know you know what i mean
hit hit hit the subscribes and all that
and so we could uh
grow riffing with griffin and make it
bigger than it make it bigger than ever
but thank you very much i appreciate
that
um
so anyways
you know so you have to just like you
know you have to ask yourself so i think
that i think that there's like a feeling
right now of like i think we again i
think we were slapped i think the whole
country was slapped and i think there's
now it's like clearly like i want to go
see comedy
you know you know it's like i'm of the
feeling and this is my intent i talk
about a lot of different things like i
got us a bid up on my instagram right
now about like from my 2017 special the
ugly truth where you know i i the
premise i set up is just basically
you know
i it's like you know people are fat and
it's like being fat to me being fat okay
if you want to be fat be fat right but
like it makes things harder like you
know if you're if you're also trying to
be
you know
whatever you're trying to do in life
being fat doesn't make it's not easier
to be fat if it's something mental you
know yeah but if you're like a crusader
or you're trying to do something it's
harder to do it
it makes it more difficult so that's the
premise i set up and then like the funny
part is i pick someone like you know
helen keller i said well you know if
helen keller was fat you know she's
already deaf and blind you know so i
that's i'm poking fun that way and then
i had then i also use anne frank as an
example like what if anne frank was fat
you know what i mean like she up in an
attic you know you know anyway it's like
you could say i'm being mean-spirited
but i like using like i like using
examples like that to really
put home the point but my intent
i move the belief that everyone should
be talked about
like i'm the belief like
i like talking about everyone people
with disabilities i don't care because i
feel like if you have a disability and
you're trying to live in society that
you want to be a part of society and
being being a part of society is also
being talked about like i love like i
have i have jokes about people in
wheelchairs
you know and
always there's somebody in a wheelchair
in my show and they love it like i'm
talking about they want to take pictures
afterwards they're having a good time
because i'm not being mean spirited i'm
making fun of everyone i think
everyone should be made fun of
i think everyone can be the butt of the
joke
the levels of how you how you feel about
it or you know
because i think people that people that
are like
oh my god i can't believe you're talking
about that i think that's a you problem
i think that's because you are the one
making a judgment like as if only normal
people i'm putting my air quotes up for
the people listening only normal people
can be talked about whatever that means
no man like if you got a disability and
you out here just trying to do your job
i think you deserve criticism too if
you're on the job you know what i mean i
don't care what your thing is but you're
on the job so what what not like like a
waiter that like you know you got
whatever disease or whatever you got is
making it hard for you to walk or
whatever it's like
should you have that job if you have the
job then you should be held accountable
so i'm of that feeling my comedy is
about holding everyone accountable
regardless of who you are or what's
right or wrong with you and i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
that's just my intent so i have to as a
comic find a way to say these words in a
way that it doesn't come across
i don't know mean spirited or but
there's always going to be people who's
going to take it the wrong way there's
always going to be people who are going
to be like oh man i don't like that you
said that or you know they always going
to have this like weird intention so you
know what i mean it's like what do you
what it's like what are you supposed to
do man you know what i mean like what
are you supposed to do so
you know i don't know
you know i don't i don't know
i don't know how to
you know i don't know how to feel about
it
uh i just have to you just as a comic
you just have to do what you have to do
you know what i mean you just do it and
then you and you know you're not going
to please everybody you know it would be
like having like oh so now before i do a
show i have to like put out i have to
pass out a survey before i start the
show and i'm going to be like okay i'm
going to talk about this does this
trigger anyone then everybody in the
crowd has to be like oh there's like two
people like yeah i'm triggered you're
like okay well we can't talk about that
uh we'll take that off the list okay
well i want to talk about uh
you know uh work and people like ah well
you know i'm kind of triggered by that
because i had a bad week at work okay so
we can't talk about work
all right i want to talk about people
with kids oh you know what i have kids
and i think that's uh you know that's
rude and you're like okay so we can't
talk about kids like if we did that
what could we talk about
like how boring would that be
you know i feel like comedy is supposed
to like inspire or comedy supposed to
rattle your thinking or comedy is
supposed to make you laugh at something
that you wouldn't normally laugh at i
mean isn't that what you think like you
know if you're in the chat right now
what is comedy to you
like what is coming to you and you'll
see from what people are writing in the
chat you're listening right now or in
the comments right now what is comedy to
you
sometimes it's people that are like you
know some people like the shocking stuff
some people like super dirty jokes some
people are like hey i want clean
wholesome comedy it it's it varies like
everybody's got a different thing
you know so what is it to you because
it's a comic remember we're one person
in front of an audience of hundreds of
people sometimes thousands of people
depending on where you're performing or
if you're on tv millions of people like
how do you please everyone there's no
possible way there's always gonna be
someone out there who's gonna be like oh
man i didn't appreciate that because of
a b and c
so is it up to the comic to make sure
that everyone that's watching feels good
or you as an audience member can you
take some responsibility for your own
feelings
and maybe be like oh you know what uh
this isn't for me and let me just maybe
not watch anymore or move on from this i
mean you know could could that be
the the the the thing
you know
i don't know
um
you know of course like it's sometimes
it's it's edgy to some people like some
people are saying here um you know
something like somebody say justin d is
saying comedies and saying naughty
things you know there's some people that
believe that like you go to a comedy
show because you want to hear something
nasty
you know like the comments going to talk
about sex or you know some people think
that comedy um you know they wanna they
want satire or they want uh they wanna
have some sort of cerebral thought
process they want it to be like highbrow
comedy that makes you go
like gabe you know some people like the
goth clap comedy where they go oh that
was brilliant what you just said some
people like that you know but i think
comedy is changing you know comedy is
changing you know this idea of comedy
specials is changing like what is a
comedy special is it like i'm old school
so i'm like traditional i like the idea
of like just being funny making people
laugh telling solid jokes having a point
of view
and uh you know
hitting it hitting it making people just
enjoy themselves but that's changing you
know it's changing i mean there is no
right or wrong way i mean with so many
comedy specials so many outlets for
comedy how can
one way of thinking be correct you know
you got comedy central hbo uh you got
amazon you got epics you got so many you
know netflix you got so many places
there's so much comedy there's gonna be
overlap there's gonna be like
oh i've seen this before i've seen this
joke before i've seen this style before
i've seen so now it becomes like is is
it personal to that person
and i say all this to talk about right
now uh a comedy special that i just
watched okay i just watched a comedy
special and i don't even know if i can
even call this a comedy special but a
comedy special from my my good friend
this is one of my best friends in the
whole wide world
gerard carmichael
um i've known jerome carmichael now over
10 years
i consider him like he he literally is
one of my best friends um
and
he put out a comedy special
on hbo you can see it right now it's
called rathaniel
and it is
it is one of the most beautiful pieces
of art uh i've ever seen shout out to bo
burnham who was the director of this
and it was just
shot beautifully i mean i could
appreciate
so many things about this comedy special
and i want to give my friend his kudos
his flowers because there's so many
different things that i loved about this
i loved the music i loved the choices i
loved the intro the intro was this
sweeping dramatic scene you know it
opens up with a light uh you know a
light pole like you know an outside lamp
and it's just you know this beautiful
shot with the snow coming down and you
know with this beautiful jazz music
playing in the background and then
you're watching gerard like walk across
the street then they you know they shoot
you see from the outside of this great
jazz club in new york and he's like
giving his coat and hat and jacket to
his someone you know and then he just
goes right on stage and the special
starts he he he sits down and he just
starts talking and he's he makes it like
just super intimate environment with
you know the crowd where he's he's
encouraging them like hey if you want to
talk to me talk to me and you know i you
know in this whole the whole specials
about him
being honest about himself uh being
honest like really vulnerable and honest
uh you know he comes out of the closet
you know i already knew this about him
but like you know
now for the world he just you know and
he talks about how this has affected him
and his family and and uh how he's
looked at and just how he's dealt with
uh trauma in his life uh with his family
but it is just and he's funny like
jarrod is a very smart guy and it's
funny but it's not a traditional comedy
special so i totally get if
you don't
like it
like if you're a person that wants to
see traditional stand-up comedy i get
that you don't like it all right i loved
it i loved it because
it you know it like
it was i love the artistic value of it
one and two i loved how honest he was in
this
and it was like so original to him
gerard carmichael is one of a kind
he is one of a kind and so many people
have tried to like imitate what he's
done
for instance chris rock um in um what
was the special he just did um
oh man i'm never prepared
but like uh he just did a special the
the the tambourine that's that's what
it's called so he did a version of
tambourine and bo burnham directed it
and i can tell that it was he was
influenced by
draw carmichael's previous special eight
and it was like that's i think that's
why he got boda directed hey direct my
special i want to be intimate like that
but it wasn't one of chris brock's
better specials
and
he
re-released it he like re-edited the
same special
and he put his stank on it and it is one
of his like it
it is so different like i recommend you
watch both
and you'll be like wow this is like
editing is a big deal and it's like so
much better because it's him
it's like what we love about him
and i realized this from watching that
and seeing that experience that you know
because i've even watched gerard and
thought like man i wish i could do that
or why am i not more like this and i
realized that what he did
is he put out a special
that was so personal to him and original
to him that that's the inspiration
the inspiration is to be the best
version of you
no matter what that is
own
you
own what you do best
be proud of it
put that out and bam
and i and that's i mean i was in the
green room and and and because it was
saturday night that it came out and then
he was also on snl
so
uh you know i'm watching it in the green
room between shows and i couldn't stop
watching and i was just like so
emotional and moved because i know him
so well i really you know i love this
kid you know and
i was looking at it and then i was like
now i have to go on stage and i was
really just like oh my god can i even do
comedy again i was just so you know you
had these moments where you're just like
oh my god like you see somebody do
something that you admire and you're
just kind of like oh man what can i do
but it just really gave me some
confidence to be more like
i'm i'm me
i talk about things the way i talk about
it i pride myself on talking about
things that mo that people wouldn't
necessarily talk about and make them
funny or make it fun
even if i get under people's skin i like
to make
like out there topics fun and that's
what i do and i have to just appreciate
that about myself and give it my all
give it 100 me authentic eric griffin
because this and i i'm giving i'm this
[ __ ] is getting like eight woo-woo's
[Music]
that's how many woo-woos rathaniel's
getting dry carmichael's special on hbo
backs i highly recommend you watch it
even if you don't like this type of
thing watch it and just feel the words
that i'm saying that it was just one of
these things that's like totally
authentically a person
you know and i've seen him grow his
first special was at the comedy store
live at the comedy store and it was like
it was different it was like you know he
has sort of like contempt for stand-up
comedy because he don't want to do it
the way people do it and then he did
this one eight he called it eight and it
was like in the round at this place in
new york and i remember he opened up the
special like mid-joke
like mid-joke like so the special opens
and he's already telling a joke like as
if he's already been there like 40
minutes and then he just goes into the
thing and then like it ends on like a
cliffhanger you know like like what else
are we going to talk about and i
remember like and it got like it was
critically acclaimed and you know it was
just one of these things where you just
go wow that was just fascinating i think
it was more him and then he like
directed drew michael's special uh they
had no audience and i wasn't a fan of
that uh you know but that to me was
jerrod putting his jarrodness on other
people
you know like he's directed a little
rail special live from crenshaw and it
was like you saw a time lapse happen
because like the sun was up and then you
saw the sun go down during the special
it was shot a certain way but once again
that was a girard thing and i feel like
those experiences he took from those
doing those specials and seeing other
people and and
and and seeing how
and finally like at 34 uh years old now
just being in the business and and now
he just found a way
to put out something that he was truly
passionate about that was truly personal
that was truly vulnerable
like i'm telling you don't go watch this
looking at it like it's a comedy special
you got to go look at this it's like
this is like
like a like a conversation this dude was
having with us like a super personal
conversation and
my god it was shot so
beautifully
like it was really shot well good like
kudos again to uh bo burnham man
and if you've seen bo burnham stuff like
beau has his own style he does for
himself but the dude has a way of just
capturing the essence of the person and
what they're trying to do man and it
just
those two guys they have the
relationship they have
uh that that conversation they have as a
director and artist
and producer and all the things that the
relationship they have with each other
that that
that you see on screen the the the
result of it it was
magnificent
okay so
kudos once again to those guys and
you know shout out to
you know jerrod carmichael and
my man
all right
okay so now um
you know let me continue to pay some
bills
once again shout out to uh helix sleep
y'all
a sponsor of the show i have a healing
sleep mattress and i'm telling you i
love it every time i get back from off
the road i'm thinking about this
mattress because i'm thinking about like
how the hotel mattress is terrible uh
getting a good night's sleep is so
important i go to this um
health place next health shout out to
them and uh the thing they ask all the
time like when you go to the doctor when
you go to like any kind of preventative
medicine place they talk about three
things all the time they talk about your
diet
all right they talk about what's your
sleep are you sleeping and then they go
to are you exercising and the order of
importance of those things it's probably
it probably goes sleep diet and then
exercise so a good night's sleep is
super important so
and then like you know with the stresses
of everything that's been going on you
know you don't even realize that you're
not getting a good night's sleep because
of the thing that you're sleeping on and
when's the last time you even changed
your mattress guys helix sleep has a two
minute sleep quiz you complete it they
match it to your body type and your
sleep preference and it's the perfect
mattress for you you don't got to go to
a mattress store you just go to sleep
helix sleep i took the sleep quiz i'm a
side sleeper and it's a perfect for me
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress and
the mattress is matched to you and they
send it right to your door helix is
awesome but you don't got to take it
from me
uh it was the number one overall
mattress pick for 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
griffin they have a 10-year warranty and
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you
if you don't love it but trust me you
will
that's helix helixsleep.com
all right y'all so uh
you know after last last week's dramatic
episode where i was just going in about
this stuff i want to get back to
something that i love to do and what is
that thing that i love to do y'all i
love to uh oh that's not it
i'm doing this by myself uh i want to
talk about
um
this movie that i saw okay
i want to talk about
morph more morbius what's the name of
this movie is it morbius yeah morbius
let's talk about morbius
um
it's starring um what's his name jared
leto
jared leto you know
jared leto
uh
matt smith adria or jonna
yeah morbius man you know i'm like i'm
on the imdb page now for everybody
that's
looking
um i don't know i got an imd rating of
5.2 uh it's just you know it's in the
marvel universe i've actually never
heard of this marvel character before
you know i'm not i'm not that deep into
the marvel world where i know all the
like the b and c characters or the d
characters from the marvel universe you
know so i don't know
but
let's talk about morbius so morbius you
know his name's michael morbius
which is kind of ridiculous
you know
you know like michael morbius i don't
know it'd be like eric erroneous or
something i don't know it'd be like it's
it's a weird like why was his name
michael i mean i feel like this is one
of those i think this is one of stan
lee's lazy characters that like they
just dug into the well like sony's like
oh here's all the characters we own in
our thing who can we make a movie about
because the movies are so successful and
they were like oh let's pick this guy
and they get jared leto uh
i i like jared leto i think he's a
really fantastic actor
i think his talents are misplaced
sometimes i think they put him in movies
where you're just like you know i don't
know like when he was the joker i mean
the first the first iteration of his
joker i think it was too much but i
thought there was some moments where i
was like oh this is pretty good and like
i've said in past podcasts i liked him
in the the snyder cut of batman at the
end i thought that version of his joker
was actually pretty good
but anyways this is morbius who's like a
doctor
so what's the premise of the movie a
biochemist michael morbius tries to cure
himself of a rare blood disease but he
inadvertently infects himself with a
form of vampirism instead
my buddy al madrigal shout out to al
madrigal owner of all things comedy the
the people that put out my podcast so
shout out to them shout out to al al's
in this movie he's really funny al's
always a good comic relief
and then like tyrese is in it
he just looks like he always looks like
the guy from fast and furious
i know he is the guy from fast and
furious but even i'm saying even as a
character like you know i don't know
like for some reason like they're the
only cops in this whole city i mean
i'll be honest it was this was not my
favorite sony marvel movie it just
wasn't
the story has some holes
so like he's got this blood disease and
you know they kind of give like his
origin story
you know you know and they have this
other character
excuse me his friend who also has this
disease and they're in like this sort of
like
care center
you know and then
of course they're bullied and you know
whatever and then like cut to later he's
become this like world-renowned
scientist and he invented synthetic
blood and he's been trying to cure
himself and his friend
of this rare blood disease and then he
like works in that field
so somehow he discovers that that you
know
vampire bats and like of course they got
to go to costa rica and
some weird cave
and then he like you know is splicing
dna human dna with bat dna to sort of
like
you know
cure himself and
you know and it goes haywire and then
like he becomes like
this super powered thing which is like i
always reject this premise because i
feel like
why wouldn't we like why wouldn't that
have been figured out and like we
wouldn't why wouldn't we we'd be
splicing human dna with other things to
make ourselves better and um like he
would be he's the first scientist in two
and you know in 500 years to figure this
out you know what i'm saying like so i'm
always like okay you know what i mean
like even the spider-man one is like
they at least said these are genetically
altered spiders and one of them gets
away and bites spider-man so you're like
okay
you can sort of be like well all right
they're genetically altered and blah
blah blah blah right uh and that's why
that happened and uh but this one was
just like so he gets like he becomes a
vampire but not like a traditional
vampire and then it's like this really
far-fetched
story about you know him and
you know this weird love interest and
then the friend and then the friend gets
it and then like you know it's just the
story is so muddled and then they like
sort of set up a sequel and you're just
kind of like what and then it's sort of
involved in the mcu you know you have to
wait and see later well you already know
michael keaton's in it so it doesn't
matter so like michael keaton was in
that last spider-man which was sony
so
there's like a crossover so i don't know
if like they've completely removed like
the avengers people and guardians of the
galaxy and you know thor and all the
people that are left and black with no
black widow's dead but you know wanda
and all these people like i don't know
if they've removed that completely and
now sony and them are branching off and
you know they've sort of removed
spider-man because of the last movie
they've made it so they don't actually
have to send him back because nobody
remembers him blah blah blah and then
like whatever the multiverse thing that
happened you know this is like an
extension of that because the michael
keaton character shows up and i believe
he's like the goblin now or i don't know
you know so he's there so they set up
that him and morbius are gonna be like
partnered up and but are they bad guys
i have no idea you know it's just it was
so just
far-fetched that
i don't know like
i don't say don't watch it but you don't
have any expectations man like really
lower your expectations because it was
just kind of blah
and you kind of hope though that if
they're
because not all of the marvel movies
were great movies especially the origin
movies like captain america the first
one that wasn't a very good movie two of
the thor movies were not good you know
what i'm saying like two of them suckers
were not good but they still put and
then it turned into something great and
so now you know so maybe they'll do this
with this and then like he made
reference to venom so that means like
this is like venom exists in this
universe so it's like is there going to
be some kind of morbius venom crossover
it's like and then spider-man's going to
be there it's like i don't know
i don't know so
you know we've already seen the best
version of this the best version of this
is they set up for 13 years the avengers
it was great we loved it so now you just
kind of be like are they trying to do
the same thing on sony side and it's
just it's hard to tell
you know what i mean oh no
so i i just i don't know how to feel
about it i don't know if this is
you know gonna be this like you know
grand thing i don't know how it did in
the box office this past weekend and you
know i don't know if like is it worth it
because these kind of movies with all
the special effects are just so like
it's so expensive right
and um i haven't watched moon night yet
so i'm gonna do that next week on the
show because i have to watch that i
think it's like a six part series but
that one i believe is more involved with
the
mcu with eternals and all those you know
that's like the continuation of that you
know so we'll see how that's gonna
affect that universe so it's hard to
tell like
you know i think our minds like we it's
hard to keep track of all this and i
think they're making a mistake you know
because it's like your mind is like okay
is spider-man since spider-man was a
part of the mcu like do the eternals
exist in this universe with these people
or is this part of this whole multiverse
thing and then now doctor strange is
going to come out and then you think
about also loki on disney plus how loki
and the time cops and you know it's like
what is this all connected you know so
you're trying to just like keep track
and it's just it's fracturing our brains
because we're just kind of like get to
the point where we're just like ah this
is all separate you know but but but i
don't know
but
people are telling me that the moon
night episode was really good so i
really uh
i will check that out you know i'm gonna
check that out but it's just
i i just don't know so i mean i give uh
morbius maybe like two woo-woos you know
what i mean
[Music]
i know and then like it's you know this
is somebody talking about the x-men like
is the x-men gonna come out
uh yeah i just i don't know you know
it's like the x-men gonna be a part of
that i mean do you i would you know i
like the idea of them all being together
like i just like that you know i think
it's better for us i mean the
entertainment value of having like
all of these characters being on the
screen together i mean that was just
what was fantastic about the avengers
mcu man because it was like these are
all big time actors that had solo movies
it was like so they're they're big
enough where they're in the solo movie
they're not a big character in another
movie but they did that for us and i
think it was great you know even when it
was a captain america movie here comes
iron man who's this bit larger-than-life
character
uh you know who's that you know he's a
star in his own right as an actor he
could you know he could carry a movie
and he just comes over to be like a part
of this other movie and i think we love
that you know they had a whole like you
know so you have like guardians of the
galaxy they have a whole series of
movies on their own and they're kind of
like in the avengers too so you just i
love that i mean i wish
if you go back to the 80s it would have
been great to have like
the you know if arnold schwarzenegger at
the height of his
you know and then him and sylvester
stallone and bruce willis you know would
have been together and you know what by
the way i'm i'm so glad i brought up
bruce willis you know and but that's my
morbius review guys we're we're done
with morbius you know that's the morbius
review um
i think this is some sad news about
bruce willis i think he i think the the
the the condition he has is called
aphasia
i think that's what it's called you know
let me let me look it up
um and it's affecting his
it's affecting his cognitive abilities
um
yeah aphasia that's what it's called
um and now he had to retire from acting
and you know it's weird because even
though he was making some [ __ ] movies
man like i mean
hit the last five or six movies that
boosted us came out with are just
and now we're finding out like
you know why
he just he wasn't himself
and
i just want to like give him his kudos
you know bruce willis just just going
back to die hard when die like die hard
was so good like die hard stands up
today like
if you've never watched die hard if
you're too young and you don't remember
die hard you just remember like the the
later ones that are like whatever go
watch the first die hard man that is
just it's still a great movie it stands
up just the everyman
you know it's like here's like a dad you
know just a regular dad being a hero
that was just a throwback to those type
of days and it's just such a great movie
and he was great in it and he's just
been great ever since he's been in some
really great iconic movies and you know
i just shout out to bruce willis man and
his family you know i'm sorry that he's
dealing with this and it just sucks
because
you know when you have a star like that
he's kind of like sort of in our lives
you know what i mean like he's just like
he's just there and even if it's a
shitty movie we're like ah bruce willis
is back here's bruce willis doing this
or we see him at an award show or you
know we see him pop up on the news and
and we just kind of like oh he's still
in our lives he's still around you know
we kind of think of him as like that
uncle that only we only see him at
thanksgiving and then there he is and
we're just kind of like ah there's uncle
bruce you know and now he's just reta he
has to retire we'll probably never see
him in the public eye again because of
like what this does because it's like a
form of like you know he's just not
himself you know he can't he he can't
communicate he's having he was having
trouble remembering his lines and you
know these stories are coming out how
people were on set and they were like
legitimately concerned for him you know
and i totally understand because like as
my mom has dementia i totally understand
like you know you're seeing this person
and you think that they're okay and then
some crazy [ __ ] comes out their mouth
and you're just kind of like oh my god
what's going on so i know it must be
hard you know and and here we are just
you know we don't know you know what i
mean like you know but by the way and
that goes back to just to bring it full
circle about jokes and comedy
like if we've been making jokes about
like bruce willis bad movies and then we
find this information out it don't mean
that our jokes weren't funny that's just
new information and the jokes could
still be funny you know what i mean it's
still like i mean i'm sure that if he
was in his right mind he would look at
this and be like yeah i did make some
bad movies that's how you'd like to
think it doesn't mean you're a terrible
person or if a comic is a terrible
person because he was making jokes about
this later or even about like what's his
name from black panther you know the guy
that died you know no one knew he had
cancer but people were making jokes
about his weight loss and you know he
just kept it to himself i mean to me he
did it the way he's supposed to do it he
was like this is a me issue everybody
else live your life comics live your
life
yeah i'm dealing with this but i don't
want to make it about that because then
he becomes this kind of sad figure and
everybody's got to like you know be like
oh
you know and it's like
that's not that's not how it should work
so i always respect that he did it like
that i always respected he like
he he was suffering he was dealing with
it and he but he dealt with it on his
own it's not our business
you know it's not our business he just
you know he just was like i'm gonna like
do what i do you know what i mean damn
it just chair
um and by the way everybody in the last
episode i did not fart in the last
episode okay
like when you move this chair makes
unless you hate that when the chair
makes sort of like a noise then you
can't replicate it
then people like you farted so i mean
this is like like half the comments i
heard that fart at 51 whatever minutes
but actually i don't you know i need to
listen to it maybe i did fart i was so
passionate that the fart just came out
who knows
i mean everybody farts why why you gotta
get on me you know i'm 50 years old you
know i don't even have control of my
body anymore you know what i mean so
you just oh you just confirmed the fart
i don't know i you know i i need to go i
need to go and check this out and
confirm this fart okay i need to go
confirm this fart
and then i will get back to you and see
if this is if that's a real thing but
other than that
it is what it is
um
but again just to get back to it you
know
shout out
to bruce willis
i think bruce willis had a really
fantastic career i think we were lucky
to have somebody like that in our life
share their talents and
good or bad and it was just you know it
was uh fantastic you know what i mean
um
oh i see somebody asked me a question uh
super super chat question now i will
respond to questions and comments right
now so you know raquel who donated 20 to
the show and i appreciate that do you
think the academy will have chris rock
host the oscars next year
um i mean i think that would be a great
move you know and i think we would all
watch to see what he has to say and all
this kind of stuff but
i don't think he will i don't think he
would want to do it i think he kind of
would just be like ah you know what that
was a moment it still was a shocking
thing that happened and i think it
sucked for him
so i don't know you know i don't know
maybe by then he's over it he could just
like make jokes about it and whatever
you know so that it so that is what it
is you know i do have some last thoughts
about that too is like something that
happened last week was that
will smith uh resigned from the academy
and i got a problem with that
i think that they should have rejected
his resignation and then removed him
officially themselves so he could be in
the lines of like he embarrassed himself
he embarrassed the academy i think that
like all of the the the all of the the
pushback and all of the things that are
coming down on him right now are
deserved it was an embarrassing moment
for everyone and so you know it is what
it is what it is and so now he's
completely out of the academy
um
you know and it's like okay
you know that's just it's just like when
we look back at it now and we're like no
emotions to it it just was like how what
an embarrassing sad moment for all of us
you know
just to be like oh man well you know
it's just sad so now all the things
about their family and life are coming
out and then they're they haven't really
come out publicly like i think they're
gonna like talk about it on her show
but it's like whatever i don't know if
i'll watch that or not you know so we'll
see and then chris rock just out here
doing this thing i can't wait to see if
he talks about it or how he'll talk
about it you know and if you want to see
me talking about it go check out my
you know go check out my uh
what do you call it
maybe i'll go to my instagram right now
and play
because i think i can i think i can play
i think i can play the clip on here
for you guys me talking about uh this
thing i had it on my um
i have it on my instagram
yeah so let's see let's go let's go to
you know let's go to screencap there it
is and then this is your boy eric
griffin talking about this
wait let's see the way people get mad
about it they act like chris rock came
out and he was like you old ugly bald
[ __ ]
that's how people talking about this
little innocuous dad joke that he did he
just said you know he could he just said
oh see you gi jane too then he went ah
you know
that was like a pull my finger joke
and this [ __ ] went crazy like he
was like look at this whole ugly black
ball stupid [ __ ] in the front row
that's what they acting like people are
like well you know you talk about
another man's wife what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
this you doing the [ __ ] in the front
row of the oscars
like he like they didn't know what was
gonna happen are you kidding me
everybody's like oh you going up when
you go after somebody family but like
that joke was a nothing joke it was
nothing right it was nothing and what
did he do he compared her to a female
hero
demi moore must feel like [ __ ] huh
to me is a vile thing
like what the [ __ ] are we talking about
what kind of soft [ __ ] is this that
somebody goes crazy like that when she
has a medical condition a medical
condition like the [ __ ] was on a
ventilator
and she had an iv drip in the front row
like she was like
and chris rock was like oh look at this
sick bald [ __ ]
[Music]
comparing it to a g.i jean a female hero
he could have said gollum you know what
i mean
like it could have been an actual insult
can't wait to see in the next lord of
the rings
oh [ __ ]
then yeah if he does that yeah maybe you
go after the [ __ ]
but a dad joke what's wrong with these
[ __ ]
some soft [ __ ] man
yeah so that was me
so make sure you go to my instagram i'm
putting up more comedy oh by the way
yeah so they're actually you know since
we're watching my comedy to end the show
like you know let's uh actually i don't
wanna you know what i can't even play
that because i might get you know as
funny as i might get flagged for playing
pieces of my special because it's like
it's weird how that works but
anyways check out my instagram
um
you know check me out
uh follow me please and uh you know once
again i'm also on uh so like again make
sure you subscribe
share
you know what i mean let you know
help help me uh
uh support the show you know what i mean
and um
catch me every day on twitch
you know i'm a twitcher so come check me
out there
love that
i appreciate you guys for being here
uh thanks for listening to my
perspective
you know we'll see uh what happens in
the world right now you know what i mean
but i appreciate all of you thanks for
all the super chats raquel mkels
uh oh we got a new member you know check
you can be a member or hit me up on
youtube because when i put my patreon
stuff up i have it on here for members
only
and i have it on patreon
omi queen thank you for the super chat
misinformed raquel again mkels gn
whatever your name is and mr kells
thanks for the super chats guys thank
you for the support and as always
this been ripping with griffin
and i will see you
see you next
[Music]
it with your week
[Music]
taking care of me
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait you gotta keep going
tv with 20.
[Music]
but you can't make your own
[Music]
all right y'all
thank you very much you guys have been
super supportive
i really appreciate it and i will see
you
next
week
goodbye
[Music]
you